say something nice
dark water now i know that
normally whenever i talk about episodes
of doctor who in general i lump together
two parters as a
single story and that's also how i was
doing overdue
doctor who review for take two doctor
who review i am
actually going to address them as
separate entities because
that's how i talked about them in the
initial
reviews of all of these things so it
felt like the best way to
deal with them again so while i'll
probably lump them together
at the end of this when i'd rank the
episodes of this series
for each episode you are going to get an
individual video and this is the first
half of the two-parter that closes
out series eight
it's pretty good there's some bits that
don't quite work but for the most part
it's pretty there's also a couple
logical fails but i mean
let's be completely honest most doctor
who stories have some logic fails
the question is whether or not the story
is strong enough
to power through those logic fails or
make it so you don't really
care all that much like i pointed out in
blink
who the heck threw that rock at the
beginning and why because i can't think
of an answer that makes any possible
sense
in any way whatsoever but ultimately
does it matter does it detract from my
enjoyment of that episode no so whenever
i
point out these nitpick things unless i
specifically say it really kind of
wrecks it for me
just take it as me going oh that's a
little
off i don't mean to put a ton of weight
on those and that's going to be the case
here when i point out a couple of
logic fails if it's something deeper
than that i will say so
but there's a bit going on here so we
have
the death of danny pink the standoff
between clara and the doctor
at the volcano the explanation of the
nethersphere
the reveal of who missy is the reveal of
the cybermen there's
a lot going on and it moves at a pretty
good clip to actually get it all in
i think normally this would annoy me but
i think it helps that the episode is
as segmented as it is by that i mean
rather than trying to juggle all these
things at the same time it takes them
one piece at a time danny's dead
that's the first opening bit that
is isolated so now what follows off of
that
clara and the doctor at the volcano
because of her
well i was gonna say dealing with the
grief it is unable to deal with her
grief
and then we move on to the nethersphere
and get our initial explanation of that
which is kind of a payoff something
that's been teased across the series
we get 3w you know it locks off each bit
before moving on to the next in a way
that makes it
fairly easy to follow despite how much
is being done
in one episode if i were to look out on
paper
how many different major things are
going on in this episode i would think
this is too much you can't do this all
in one episode but
it works and it gets away with it
because it is sure to
tie off the first thing before going on
to the next so
that that's it's well structured all
things considered
so some of the things that i really like
first off
props to this thing because i
i paid attention during the next time on
doctor who
at the end of the previous episode which
did not
reveal the cybermen which was to my
memory now also to my memory
the marketing like not
the next time on doctor who but like bbc
marketing in the lead up to the finale
did reveal the cybermen and
boo on them but if you managed to avoid
the marketing
that moment that reveal of the two doors
cl
well first of all you see the 3w logo
which is the circle with the smaller
circle
and it's you don't think much of it
and then you see the two doors close and
you see those things side by side
and you hear the musical sting for the
cybermen and you realize
oh crap it is great
it's a great moment i didn't know that
they were in this
when i watched it the first time so that
moment got me watching it again
moment got me again love it it is
fantastic so that's really good the
reveal of missy i've talked about before
in my list of top 10 doctor who twists
although in hindsight part of me thinks
i maybe should have for that list swap
that out with the
sasha dewan master reveal i don't know i
i'm not
sure i i stand by that inclusion uh uh
over the other one but it
anyways moving on from that i do still
really like this reveal
i like the buildup i like that you know
we get missing there's been an
ominousness to missy but like we haven't
really known what her deal is
but we're getting so much now like the
fact that she
just enjoys messing with people
and it's so clear early on like she's
just toying with him but you don't know
why
not all of that works some of it does
some of it doesn't like the kiss
the kiss doesn't work unless you already
know who missy is so
that's a bit that works in hindsight
it's like oh yeah that's that's kind of
awesome and that tracks but watching it
in isolation for the first time
it just kind of comes out of nowhere and
it's weird and it's the kind of moment
you don't necessarily remember when you
get the big reveal you don't suddenly go
back and
oh so the kiss and like it's a thing
because
there is so much distance between when
that kiss happens and when the reveal
happens and a lot of very significant
stuff happens in between so like that's
a moment
for instance that doesn't totally work
missy messing with him
does oh and i've seen a lot of people
complain about the whole
why didn't the doctor like feel that
this was
a time lord or the master right off like
well
they addressed that in one way and then
i have a headcanon for the rest of it
they kind of address that because it is
established that when he puts his hand
on her chest
he does feel two hearts but he is either
choosing to compartmentalize that
because
he's not in a position to deal with what
that means right now he's on another
mission or
he doesn't quite know what that means
and he had
and he doesn't know how to process that
and and so either one of those
but in addition my head canon because
people tend to cite
david tennant being all you know if
there were other time lords i would feel
them and i don't it feels like i'm alone
or maybe it was
eccleston who said i think they both
said something to that effect
the reason why i feel like that doesn't
apply here is
the reason he would have felt that
before is because he was the
only time lord still around
now that meant that any other
time lord would have been picked up by
his raider but at this point
gallifrey's say now i mean like he
hasn't found it again yet but
gallifrey's saved
and he knows that he's not the only time
alert anymore and so that sort of radar
basically is gonna have a lot less focus
to it at least that's my head cannon on
that some people don't agree
whatever it i feel like it's a minor
point so
the whole thing with the dark water
it's both clever and contrived because
in universe there isn't really a reason
to do that as opposed to
just have them in
walled off mausoleums in coffins there
isn't a reason to have them on display
in universe especially with this weird
water that doesn't show
the uh the exterior shell you know
anything non-organic
there's really no reason to do that
other than the fact that it makes for an
awesome reveal and a very cool
way to hide the cybermen in plain sight
and it is very good at that but
the in-universe reason as to why the
dark water exists like
i'm not sure i buy that okay let's talk
about the don't cremate me
now that got a lot of people really
upset so far as i can tell because i
think it you know
it's a concept that is
terrifying it's a legitimately horrific
concept
it's been done in straight up horror
stories tales from the crypt did an
episode
kind of like based on this idea and
moffat seems to also have latched on to
it because he kind of
picked it up again um with his dracula
but i'm
i'm kind of okay with now granted i
haven't had like
my kid doesn't watch doctor who so i
haven't had to like explain
or deal with her being traumatized by
that so maybe
some people have a different perspective
if you've had to deal with that kind of
thing
but for me i watch it and go yes that's
a horrifying idea
but all of it gets called into question
in terms of its accuracy
almost immediately because like we're
looking at this piece of technology and
the doctor is sniffing a rat on this
whole thing
so while it is a terrifying concept i
don't feel like the episode itself
ever really goes in hard on the idea
that that's actually what goes on
at least that's my read on it again
other folks
if you were legitimately disturbed by
that no fair
it is a uh it is a disturbing concept
let's talk a little bit about danny pink
and
how things sort of play out there i have
mixed feelings
about his death and the way that
plays out for a couple of reasons the
first is
that i i appreciate the suddenness of it
but at the same time it doesn't quite
land as well as it should and thinking
about it i think
sudden unexpected deaths are
really hard to do in
dramatic television because on the one
hand
it is true to life sometimes people die
for absolutely no reason and at points
in time where it's like
what the hell is that like clara says
like that's
boring how can that be the end of his
life story that's so
boring and that does happen i think the
problem with trying to milk drama out of
that
is it's it almost always comes off in
one of two ways
it's either contrived and like you
pulled that out of your butt just to
milk
drama like just out of nowhere a
character dies what
or it comes off as unintentionally
comedic
that's where you get things like micho
black
and that rather infamous clip but
the this whole thing of trying to
do sudden deaths sudden unheroic
unremarkable deaths for drama i think
it's just
really hard to find a way to balance
that unless you're like
basing the story around it like say a
spoiler alert for a very old book uh
like
bridge to terabithia where the entire
latter half of the story
is about dealing with that
so i i'm not sure it works quite as well
as it should that said it works better
than most instances
instances i've seen of this sort of
thing being attempted
seriously and dramatically the
issue for me uh there's a couple of
things
the first is the whole thing opens with
clara
getting ready to tell danny the truth
and this is bad because it makes it
it immediately throws into question
their relationship because this means
and i meant to address this in the
previous
review so let me sort of make up for
that
this means that after the events of
flatline
where he heard her offer these
ridiculous explanations for what he was
hearing
over the phone including her crashing
through a window
and he and he could clearly tell
something was up
that they either never had a
conversation
about what the heck was going on or she
somehow talked her way out of it
which i have a hard time buying because
the few times we've seen her try and lie
to danny
she's really bad at it so
it it means that like something's wrong
with their relationship and now we
it's kind of compounded because in the
forest of the night
they have these moments where danny's
like look i just want to know what's
going on
just don't lie to me and it's very clear
that she knows she is
but they opened this episode treating it
like they've never had this conversation
before i'm like really
and it makes me question this
relationship is it as strong and as
valid as
at least clara is acting like it is
because
at the very least you are deceptive as
hell with him
and in addition to that it's like you
guys
suck at communication like across the
board and he
either is enabling you're lying to him
knowingly
or he's an idiot and believed you
which i have a hard time buying because
danny didn't strike me as that dumb
how stupid you think i am so that's
that's a little bit of a problem
i do kind of appreciate that the doctor
says you know you're a rage of chemicals
because
yeah early love is all is a lot of
hormone-driven i don't just mean that in
like sex but like you know endorphins
and everything else so
i guess it it helps a little uh to sort
of acknowledge that
that's going on so the whole volcano key
thing
i both like and i don't like i mean i
did there's the standard logistical
thing which is you can't stand that
close to lava
you can't they're dead already but you
know also
it's not real it's a dream state
although seriously why does the doctor
have those patches
from gridlock i i buy that the doctor
keeps certain souvenirs or keeps hold of
things that he thinks are too dangerous
to be anywhere else
but these were something being mass
produced and i know he told them to like
shut it down and this street is closing
tonight but theoretically these could be
made at any point again so it's not like
he's got the only ones in existence or
he can't be certain that he does
and he was so disgusted by what these
things
were why would he keep that around and
it's not like it's a unique item like i
said this was a mass-produced thing but
he just
has them and he told clara about them
that he has them
what no i i mean it's
on one hand it's a nifty callback to
gridlock and i kind of appreciate
that but it the minute i stopped and
thinking about it's like
he shouldn't have those i can't think of
any reason why the doctor would keep
those he was horrified by them on
principle
so that's one of those things that
doesn't ruin the episode for me but it
does make me go ah
hmm couple other things that i like i do
like during that argument at the volcano
which
while part of me questions you know
since i'm questioning the viability of
danny and clara as a couple it does
bring some doubt to
the level that she's taking this to like
is it worth it have they earned her
being this committed especially when she
wasn't even being honest with him but
you know then again you don't have to be
in a good relationship to be super
committed to it
that's a thing that happens but anyways
one of the things that i do
really like in that scene is the doctor
saying why
he can't save danny and i like that
because i was i was half expecting
because i couldn't remember the
specifics
i was half expecting him to just do i
can only change some things i can't
change others and to leave it at that
because that feels like usually what the
doctor does
in this case i like that he says that he
cites the specific circumstances as to
why he can't fix it
the events that brought you here you
will never come here and ask me to
change those events
paradox loop and we know from past
causing paradoxes is a big problem with
episodes like
father's day and with the paradox
machine in
the sound of drums and last the time
lord so we know paradoxes are
hugely problematic so i like that that
is cited specifically instead of it just
being the general
well i just can't not to say that i i am
not okay with the doctor just saying
that
i in most instances but she's so
committed here like
i like that he offered up more than just
i can't
um so that was good i also really like
towards the end where clara is talking
with danny
through the white noise i guess and she
is trying to get him to say something to
confirm that it's him
and you know he's i mean the guy's
befuddled as heck he
he just had an encounter with the young
boy that he
accidentally killed while he was a
soldier and
he he's obviously just really out of
sorts and he can't think of anything
initially he just keeps saying i love
you and she just gets frustrated he's
like anybody could say that
you that you saying that doesn't mean
you're dandy you say you love me one
more time
and i'm disconnecting from this and
walking away
and there's this pause and danny says
i love you
[Music]
which is him saving her because he was
afraid and i think given what we've seen
clara do
rightfully so he was afraid that she
would actually kill herself in order to
try and reach him
and he just says i love you
so that she will go through with her
threat and disconnect the call and
assume that it wasn't him
and i like that sacrifice from danny
that was really good
i think that's about all i've got on
this one obviously i'll be talking much
more about missy's scheme and the
cybermen when we talk about death in
heaven
next week um oh uh the the admin
guy in the nether sphere i really like
him
i i always kind of liked these you know
big
sort of spiritual questions or places or
realms being presided over just by
that's
bureaucracy it's just paperwork i've
always kind of liked that idea and
i like it when it comes up in things you
know how this kind of deals with it or
when it comes up in things like
beetlejuice or the good place i i
always rather enjoyed that so i like him
and i like uh his use and
characterization
quite a bit but that's dark water you
rewatched it lately
what'd you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something on down in
the comments let's talk about it
bunch of stuff to do you probably know
what it is like share subscribe
all of which help with the algorithm
which at the time of recording seems to
be starting to
kick my ass again um but in addition to
that i also have a patreon it's kind of
the big one it is
it is keeping the lights on at present
but
you also don't have to do any of that
because at the end of the day
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um